[Music]
so we've got today tomorrow
a small rest day on monday but next week
i mean i don't no point in looking ahead
we've got a crazy day
here today and you know what's hilarious
something just fell from the roof of
this building and hit my camera
i'm going to school hi everybody why is
danny going out of frame i know you want
me all right
i told you the main host
you don't need to do it this much sound
proofing sound
moving from the ceiling so the new
studio we have here is actually not
complete yet we've been doing all kinds
of stuff
and what you just saw you can't fake um
hey buddy are you gonna don't shake your
head at me like this is on me buddy
all right anna this is it you got two of
your students pokey and rubius
the xqc of of uh of
spain they call him that is that is that
a fair nickname i think
excuse the canadian rubies i must say
rubius was there before i'm gonna defend
himself
he himself memes about it he himself
screams about that so
it's all right but yeah my heart is
absolutely torn and
i work with both of them very closely i
i have five students in pakistan but
these are the two students that i have
been working the most
closely with so i especially am nervous
for both of them and how well they do
and i just wish they could
both win the match but obviously that's
not possible so i just want them to do
their best as if they were my two kids
and
made a better player win this is going
to be hard i mean the
the queen is unattacked the knight is
pinned he kind of has to find the move
queen e6 here
i think so and i was worried that if he
chooses the d6 square which
looks like a natural choice but this
runs into a discovered attack knight
takes c6
it was so difficult to react to knight
e5 i think pocky showed
a brilliant preparation bishop b595 kind
of refutes my setup because i didn't
expect such an aggressive setup
um by white in the london it's usually
c3 and everything is very calm but no
bishop b5 and 95
immediately pointing out that the knight
on c6 and the queen on d7 could get into
trouble
well and now we see we see pokey
executing perfectly the point everybody
is after knight takes c6 the queen is
under attack
and she's winning a piece
of piece like you're doing it
it's the first time that that someone
plays this against him
he's currently talking about the virgin
mary i believe
so moment of truth right now will she
see rook c7
pocky absolutely loves puzzles she she
has been on the puzzle grind from the
very beginning so i wouldn't be
surprised if she spots some of those
tactical patterns
kings because he wants to escape to a7
but he doesn't see
she found the best move discover check
and ruby start he could take the rook
but
the bishop on g3 is the killer piece you
saw him try to take the rook with the
bishop he physically grabbed it
it was like what the heck is going on
here
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
look at rubius rook c1 threatening rook
b1
oh my gosh he's setting up a last minute
mating trap
okay holy bejesus snaps
bucky needs to find a way to get some
space for her king and moving
up one square uh could
be a way actually oh but no if she has
matey one
she has made him one she also has mating
one if she had taken on a6
but that was really hidden instead she
just she just created some
space for her king now this is this is
of course brilliant too because now she
can run away with the king so
even though she didn't see the mate um
it still is checkmate
on a6 but it's quite a hidden checkmate
she was thinking more of the
safety of her kid i think now she
realizes i was thinking about the safety
of her king i didn't even see she had
maiden one um
i wasn't looking okay wow i'll
i think she will get it now bishop
before was a brilliant way to free the
king
two queens versus two rooks
should be should be good enough
now the e8 rook is hanging and also a6
that pawn on a6
has been the hidden threat for the last
couple of moves
i wonder if she will spot it now or will
she give queen d4 check which is also a
strong move
queen classy
that's a grand master play when you're
winning to just get rid of your
opponent's pieces because you no longer
care if it's an equal trade just get
them off the board so
again it's not made in one but if you're
watching as a fan and a viewer who wants
to get better
that is a very human grand master thing
to do and uh
applause is for for pokey or deserve for
that
this is trying to run with the pawn okay
is still made no i don't want to draw
sir
did ruby suffer a draw um oh ruby has
offered to draw the chess.com chat
hilarious
i was wondering what happened there
of course pocky refuses i think that was
a joke from rubio's
side i can't even hear what he's saying
but i'm reading his lips and he's
staying
styled muscles tables tables avocados
trying to get the stalemate
the problem is she's playing against
someone who knows a trick
pocky taught me that the queen should be
a night shadow away
so the shadow of the night is right now
on ca
you know
wow stables fables unbelievable
what a roller coaster here we go with
the french
and they're playing principled moves
even if they're not the theoretically
best moves in the french right because
you could argue okay if a grandmaster
sat down was playing white here they
might they might be able to do some
damage and they'd probably look to open
the center
and kind of uh punish black there but
but also it doesn't mean what pokey's
doing is wrong we know c5 is the idea
usually it comes after an e5 advance to
undermine
this d-pawn that's kind of the risk is
does rubius realize
that this isn't a normal french and that
he might have an option
just kind of blow things open right now
i'd be curious to see what he does
i wonder if he's considering those moves
he plays bishop to a4 which may create
tactical opportunities for pokey because
now the knight on c3 has too many things
to do
has to be guarding the bishop and also
has to be guarding the e4 pawn
yeah i think [__] spotting it
captures immediately yeah she doesn't
have to be asked why she takes it now
will she see she can even take with the
knight here now because she unpinned
the uh the knight to the queen this
would be okay
both are good in fact actually pawn
takes is probably even better i just
thought knight takes might have really
really shown that she understood
uh the power of bishop e7 but maybe this
is even better now she can win the
d-pawn and just
wow pokey pokey main pokey the beast
yeah i think she will castle she she
does know her opening principles very
well
um if she doesn't castle it will be
because she spots
a tactical pattern but yeah makes
perfect sense to castle
and now for rubius some of the ideas
could be to
chase that knight away from d4 because
it's a very strong piece for pocky
or try to bring the knight back from a4
because it's a bit of a
sad piece on the edge of the board pokey
needs to be
a bit careful here because queen b3 does
set
up a threat the knight on c6 can be
undermined by the capture on c6 and then
the bishop on b4 is hanging so i wonder
if she will move the bishop away or will
she spot that she could
place that knight on d4 because there's
a night fork on e2 but that's a bit
that's a bit too much way too dang oh a6
oh a6 didn't didn't guard the bishop but
now rugby won instantly by rubio so
pocky has a chance
to defend the bishop with the queen
queen e7 or queen a5
what's that tough position for him
[Music]
on trading and simplifying now and it
doesn't mean she may not see pc five
minutes
right now but but i think overall she's
had a mission and she's been sticking to
it i'm up a bunch of pollens and i'm
going to trade peace
i think she sees it i think she's just
making sure whether it's a bishop or
queen check that's better because now
the knight is hanging and the e5 bishop
too is in the air
he is on fire and improving by the by
the day
anybody watching this should be be
afraid of pokeman be very afraid
she is he is getting better at chess
it's absolutely smooth sailing she takes
the bishop on e5 and now she's
threatening bishop to c5 and i'm sure
she sees it
i'm sure she sees it because her grind
oh knight to d7
hence the night he brushes her shoulder
off no no big deal like
instantly took that night like instantly
no problem
wow yeah rubius was
rubios was drawing us an arrow to the c5
square i thought
on on his stream so
[Laughter]
what does that mean she's saying with
the i don't speak fluent coolness
i think that was a w
i'm always afraid i'm going to make an
inadvertent inappropriate sign that
means something and so i don't i don't
like to make signs with my hands
it doesn't go well maybe ruby is offered
a joe again
oh
going nuts with it lmao
i think she will spot it again she has
been on the puzzle grind
ever since she started practicing chess
so
[Music]
what's he saying
screw
because he's saying that he's gonna get
one of the pieces for free that he can
take either the d7 knight or the b4
bishop so he doesn't
see that it's checkmate here for pocky
and
i don't think she sees it just yet
either because she would have played it
already by now
shout out to mark 100 net with the 100
donation just now
we love you mark you're helping us reach
that goal i think we're going to get
there
before the day's over okay thank you so
much everyone for the contribution she
defends the bishop on b4
allowing queen takes d7 but then bishop
c5 queen f1 will be chat meeting too i
think this is what she has set up
yeah i'm sh i'm sure she sees
it here we go here we go
only move
boom so rather than going for the maiden
one she goes for the five head play of
matin two
even harder exactly exactly
no draw he keeps off
i think they might be a little biased
there might be a ruby's fan lurking
there
nada nada
i think that means nothing i don't speak
spanish
but i did statements
we went to this moment here in this
first game where you played b4
and we were talking about how while this
is a dangerous pawn
it could be one that backfires if you
recognize the c
file how early did you realize that even
though you lost this pawn that the game
was not over
and that you had a chance to make a
comeback here with this tactic
to be completely honest um pawn pushes
are a weakness of mine for sure so i was
kind of
you know i was feeling myself i was like
let's do it and immediately after i was
like oh no
he has check oh no i block with my queen
oh no he has my rook
and i was this close to resigning so
close
so close you didn't you didn't
taught me don't resign um you know
uh forget what the teacher said in
in a queen's gambit just keep playing so
i kept playing and i got really lucky
with the
uh with the discover check and finding a
tactic there so
yeah it was kind of just i i felt bad i
felt bad if i resigned there but if you
asked me for a draw in that moment i
would have accepted immediately
immediately why didn't you accept my
draws they weren't
there yeah you offered them just a
little too late
i'm like mating too and you're like draw
draw yeah it was fair and ruby is what
what were you thinking here
because and it is a good lesson for
future games right you won the rook
you took pokey's rook um but you decided
to keep the queens on the board and is
it because you just
you get nervous with the queens being
traded or were you were you not
realizing how big your advantage was if
you had traded queens
um no i i think it is the the
second thing yeah i always feel like and
that's
something i have to learn that i
sometimes have to
to trade queens right because uh
if not uh yeah the game goes very bad
for me like
like this one but one thing i want to
say is that
the the most amazing thing about these
two matches with poki
were the openings her pawn openings
it was like suddenly i had like
uh zero pounds and she had taken and
almost all of my pawns in the second
game
i don't know how she did it like nice it
took me like three minutes to realize
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm taking full
full responsibility because i think i
prepared very
very complex openings for you and pocky
knows her lines very well so she
she has been practicing the london and
the french defense and
even if even if i show you a line she
will still have more experience in it so
for next time i will know i need to go
for something simpler where we
we keep our pawns safe but i was in such
a difficult spot and
danny knows like i spent the whole match
being nervous for both of you
i wanted both of you to do your best and
i wish you could both
win um but ruby is something that i
mentioned something
anna is so sweet and cute for
my match against xqc she sent me two
videos that are like ten plus minutes
longer call me two okay these are some
things to remember
wait she's saying yeah yeah and then
against
rubius she was like three minutes hey
listen i love you guys both and i care
about you both and i hope you both win
and i'm sorry but like i'm just watching
you
and i don't know what to do and i hope
you can get it yeah she said
something i was like you're so nice yeah
she's amazing anna's amazing the best
teacher we could have
absolutely we we've known that
anna's the biggest sweetheart in the
chest we've known that secret for a
while but now the rest of the streaming
community is figuring it out she really
is
and i her coaching is evident pokey you
said in that moment when you won
you were just being honest you were like
i didn't think i was going to win a
match this whole tournament
yeah now not only have you won one you
might be one of the favorites to move on
to the championship bracket
i mean how are you feeling about your
chess right now
um i kind of just put myself into this
mindset of i'm here for a good time and
so as long as the matches are fun
i hope it's a fun viewing experience for
everyone and if that's the case then i'm
happy so
in that sense you know less nerves and
just hoping for the best yeah and rubios
i was going to tell you that
um i didn't want to tell you how the
group stage is going but
um you want a rematch against sqc
and this is your chance pocky is your
ticket to a potential rematch because
if pocky beats xqc today at the end of
the day they're gonna play today
then pocky is going to the championship
bracket and you go to the same bracket
as
xqc so i know you're not happy about the
result
no no no do you remember the video i
sent you about xqc drawing the bracket
you are going to that birthday yeah yeah
yeah okay
yeah that was if i won today okay no no
no no no it didn't matter for you
it didn't matter what you do but because
pocky won she can also win against xqc
and then xqc and you
go to the same part of the bracket and
that's what you want because you want to
prove that you are the og
you're the real rubios he is copying you
right that's what we need to prove
by the chess moves you make on the board
exactly that's the plan
yes yes yes you can play against him in
the finals it's still possible
oh cool okay pokey you have to kick his
ass today okay
i'll do my best i'll do my best all
right well uh thank you both again for
an awesome match and great interviews
pokey good luck we'll see you i guess
in a couple hours and and ruby is have a
great day and and
best of luck in maybe your future
rematch versus xqc
yeah thank you both